thank you Jeannie Thank You Maria thank
you Dan for this wonderful opportunity
of being here a second time in this
beautiful city and I what I'm going to
do is to present this topic this
question that I think that is
fascinating I hope that you will find it
that because we have we know we have
some knowledge about this topic this
area of research but we also have a lot
of unknowns and I think that this is
where it gets a little it gets very very
exciting so I'm gonna first this is I
mean we are going to talk about
respiratory infections but we actually
I'm going to focus on influencer because
it's fascinating how this is such a
known disease everybody helps it every
year it has been like their it causes a
pandemic that was a disaster you know as
you know in 1918 but if I ask you why do
we get influenced in winter and actually
if I asked the same question to any
researcher in the world the answer is
the right answer is we don't know okay
so there are several theories and I'm
going to try to show you this because
this is very well related not only with
influence a bit with many other
respiratory diseases we still don't know
that so we have good guesses you know
every one of us a oh it's you know it's
cold it's your there are a lot of people
together whatever i'm going to show you
this this this some of the basis for
these theories but something so basic we
see you don't know so you guys that are
used to get a Nobel prizes you should go
and try to sort this out because it's
time to do it seasonality of respiratory
infections so we are going to deal with
these three things okay what is it the
causative explanations so all the
theories and they on some of the
methodological challenges so this is a
little bit of a i like i like to run a
little bit so the last session if we use
artist you around you will hear about
some of the things that i think that are
interesting about
what is we can improve in some of the
ways we do research in this in this
field so seasonality first let's
understand what this is a relative
seasonality is some written that you
have you know in your data okay so this
is for instance i got we download the
data from the wh 0 about influenza and
then if you this is a very nice way by
the way of plotting your data if you
have data you know that comes from a lot
of places those are countries and then
you have several time you have time
series started doing this you know
because you have this powerful computing
machine that is the brain and can
already see a stuff going on okay so you
have and if you sorted it in a
meaningful way like like like a
latitudinal gradient used you can
already see things going on so in the
North image here you know a high
latitude you have things going in a in a
rhythm and actually if you look at that
it doesn't coincide with the soda name
is here because of course is winter
there is written is we're done here and
in the middle is the tropical areas that
we will see that are very complicated
and in some sense more fascinating so
seasonality you have a season a signal
you know and then you you can use
several models you can use one model
here the we happen to use a Fourier
analysis and then you get this you know
you simplify the information and then
you have a peek a difference between the
peak and the throw and this you have a
wave wave height when is plainly that
because the strength of seasonality is
something interesting in itself so this
will be you know the another place but
here you would say that is a week
seasonality okay because these wave wait
is it smaller than this one so this is
like you know influenza or mortality of
pneumonia you know in in a temperate
country and this will be in a tropical
country so with when you why is that
important because you have a calm
things going on here but it's something
that you can reduce to some parameters
and this and when you reduce your struct
parameters it's very good because you
can compare then across latitudes or
across age groups or you know and then
is when things greatly increasing so for
instance here you have the big time is a
very interesting thing so this happens
in somebody's happens in winter happens
in between and then you have the wave
wait so when you do that you can
generate things like this with that we
did in Brazil when you see that here you
know in the cell this is the Tropic of
Capricorn so this will be the tropical
region here you have a strong okay
amplitude of seasonality so they in
winter you have a lot of death for
caused by pneumonia and influenza and in
summer not so many as opposed to hear
and interesting enough they started
increase because this is the latitude
when you get close to the equator Cory
on line so this is something that you
can do with seasonal parameters or the
big time that is fascinating as well
because this happen to be later in the
year then those ones in the North
something that we didn't expect respect
that influenza would first arrive here
every year and then spread to the
remaining of the country and this as we
will see it's one of the reasons that we
believe that is because this coincide
with winter okay so what happens in
winter and this coincides with the rainy
season in the in the tropics so if you
interpolate this is an interpolation we
are starting to do with data which you
interpolate the timing of the influenza
you see that the tropical areas are the
ones that are more interesting you know
the temperate ones are kind of boring
they happen out the same here it's in
day in this time of the year
january-february when they peek and here
is on of july june and so on
said that okay seasonality influence
uppers seasonality is interesting per se
but also sometimes what we want to study
is what goes beyond seasonality so we
describe seasonality and we remove it to
find the interesting stuff okay so this
is the case for when you are looking at
pandemics then you have to do
seasonality not because you are
interested in seasonality but to know
what happens every year okay so you have
the rhythm and then what you do is you
get you make a model that it does not
include the year that you are looking at
okay and then you see the excess so this
is the 2009 pandemic you know data from
again from Brazil and then this is what
you had of excess of death okay so this
is also an interesting information that
you can plot through latitudes again and
see that actually in the south of Brazil
again it dies much more people that what
happened in the north of Brazil
something fascinating something that
some models didn't have take into
account when they estimate the global
burden of the pandemic and they said
that in the tropics will be the same
were the same day stroke-related the
data to the tropics and that's not the
case what as what we saw in Brazil you
really have more death in the temperate
regions done in the and this is actually
in the end equatorial regions and that's
fascinating for something that we are
going to see perhaps people don't die as
much in of influenza and other
respiratory infections in the tropics as
they do other things being equal or
equal of coral social economics and so
on as they do in in the temperate
regions if you just wonder if you like
this sort of thing could I do it yet you
can you go to cemeteries you go through
archives you get this sort of
information your do later student to
transcribe at and create the label girl
and then you have very interesting
things that you can look at so this is a
we did just for fun in Brazil in the
city I live you know so
all this was a student there that did
this beautiful work and we publish in
vaccine you know show in the epidemics
the impact of the pandemic in
Florianopolis and you can do that with
this program that up sorry I I press the
eject button i guess here which is how
does it oh thank you so this is a
program that we wrote and you can use it
for free and to do all these analysis
and other ones you have here so people
in any part of the world can do this
sort of research on time series and it
compares the data cross latitudes and so
on okay so going back to acute
respiratory infections they are the most
common illness in humans 5.5 million
deaths per year main cause of childhood
mortality and diagnosis and attribution
difficult and certain a lot of virus is
going on you don't know what what is
causing the death underlying drivers
include malnutrition pollution
overcrowding and tobacco use and you can
see where are the regions that are more
affected by the respiratory infections
this is an interesting graphic because
it's it's a model of us on in respect to
diseases to infections you know so those
are actually there ways that infections
can go can enter us you know through the
lumen elementary system through the of
course respiratory system from the
journey towel you know so sexual
diseases and so on so if you look at
this historical data set they're
fascinating because a lot of the
diseases you know mainly they did I did
diarrhea the vector borne diseases
they've been decreasing a lot but we are
not so lucky with the respiratory ones
of course we had vaccines we have a lot
of things that are improving but we
still have a lot of death by respiratory
why is that because here if you
look at this organism you remember you
can remember that okay well food we can
kind of treat food we can you come to
sanitation you can break the ways that
this thing's enter okay sexual
transmission you can use preventive
measures but air we have to breathe air
and then we always have door of entrance
for the respiratory infections okay so
this is still as if you were if you want
is the lat is the most difficult in
sexual group to be get rid of and you
have several virus that to take
adventure so this is in another place of
Brazil Fortaleza so this is a pediatric
data and you have a lot of things going
on there and those are the ones that we
don't know you know but they but you
have RSV party influenza and denominator
no more virus adenovirus influence on
you see and it's interesting that in
kids you have a lot of RSV there as you
know from other parts of of the world as
well but the same problem so this is
actually the the rainy season there as
you can see so the things that I'm going
to discuss for influenza are valid in a
great extent for the other this is
despite that that said there are some of
them you know like / influences that
they go through all the year and this is
another layer of complication of this
question that I'm not going to discuss
even because I don't know the answer as
well nobody knows yet so respiratory
tract you have upper respiratory tract
infections the ones that install mainly
here the dividers blood produces here
and then when things get dicey they come
here and then it can be much more
completely much more severe okay this
difference is interesting for aspects
like the way that some virus for the
transmission of the virus because some
of them can go up down there for
mechanism that
we'll try to see winter seasonality has
been reported for a wide range of upper
respiratory tract infections caused by
200 different viruses okay belonging to
these families but lower respiratory
tract diseases such as pneumonia viral
of bacteria also show a similar seasonal
button okay so I not talk about bacteria
you have here than one burger that knows
much more than that about me but it's
interesting to see that many other
disease that you even don't think that
our respiratory they actually had
seasonal patterns and are related
probably with their respiratory way of
transmission as well like smallpox this
is a it was this horrible disease that
has been eliminated 30 years ago it also
had actually very interesting pattern
you know and this is probably because
the way that it was transmitted is love
after you had this very nasty you know
things that explode and that that was I
realized and then people would breathe
that and that was the worst way of
transmission of did and the disease so
just by being having this respiratory
part of their cycle you had some
interesting button and they think that
we study for influenza probably will
help to understand what we why we had
these patterns in the past that
fortunately we don't see anymore because
this disease has been eradicated other
interesting stuff these are diarrheal
disease okay you say oh well so why are
we looking at the diarrhea at a direct
diarrhea time series here well in the
past this is Mexico okay so in the past
what you used to have is diarrhea death
that were in summer so you had this huge
summer peaks and then as you move you
know two more recent years actually you
get rid of the summer ones and this
actually is in winter okay
middle of the year beginning of the year
and so those are not longer probably
bacterial death but now what we do a
bacteria that diarrhea and this is viral
diarrhea okay fascinatingly enough for
reasons that we still don't understand
these winter diarrhea rotavirus and so
on they are also they follow the same
pattern as a influenza on other
respiratory diseases why we still don't
know so this is the timing offer for
instance rotavirus diseases you know and
it follows the same pattern as
respiratory ones if this is a
latitudinal gradient so this is the
northern countries and then this is a
southern hemisphere and this is a timing
so here they are more aggregated in the
wintertime and here as well in the
wintertime causative explanations so
let's first talk about the general
causes of seasonality of infections
diseases quickly so survival of pathogen
outside the host you have some micro
climate you know some water that is out
there and that in summer the conditions
are better for bacteria to multiply and
is when you have the the peak of
diarrhea for instance as we saw in
Mexico hast behavior so use for instance
the summer holidays people have changing
patterns in part partners not patterns
partners button and they got more dire
and Morgan area for instance this is a
better host immune fusion function so
you have for instance in in in some
places that get very dry and dusty in
Africa so you have more mining giants in
those times of the year and of course
you know abundance of vectors and
non-human hosts you know that when
malaria danger zone they depend on the
seasons where the mosquitoes are around
so we are not going to talk more about
the vector of unknown human hosts in
respiratory diseases because they don't
depend on that other than you probably
have heard about the thing about birds
and an influencer so the thing about the
birds and influences because the natural
reserve ettore of a of influenza is
actually wild animals and then how they
are introduced from time to time that is
when we have dependents and so on can
follow the risk of introducing can
follow some seasonal patterns okay but
this has nothing to do with the seasonal
patterns that we have is just that there
are some times where the birds you know
that have the avian influenza they are
around those hot spots they can
introduce into the human population new
variant but that's all what we're going
to talk about vectors and no human hosts
and respiratory diseases so we actually
made this kind of framework of the
putative relationship and casual
connections among key seasonal seasonal
stimulii million type mechanism and
influenza epidemics okay so those will
be the mediating mechanism I added the
transport in vital survival for reasons
we are going to see an immunity and
contact rate so you saw that apart from
the vector one we have the three ones
here and we have seasonal stimuli and
I'm by putting this whole this whole
scheme here I don't want to pass the
impression that everything is important
no I am putting everything here because
those are they all the theories that are
out there we still don't know which ones
are the correct ones okay so this is the
the size of the of the problem so let's
walk a little bit in the
they threw out the different theories
and probably you're going to find your
your favorite one here among these these
ones that I'm going to show so
temperature and contact rate okay this
is actually the most except hypothesis
and is the one that we usually listen in
the news and son o people there are more
time indoors you know so they get to
contact mode in winter you know so that
I actually don't believe that I mean
individual display for instance the
video I spend on average one to two
hours more into more time indoors during
cold weather in the USA okay and this
will be as well the valid for the
tropics because it rains more and then
you have people more time indoors during
ring weather conditions well what's the
problems and this is why I don't think
that this is a strong theory I think
that these differences seem minimal in
the 20 hours of the day mainly current
in current crowded conditions you know
that we live in urban areas so I don't
know if you guys see each other more in
winter than in summer but I think this
is basically the same the contact right
here or in metros in and there is no
empirical data for that so here there is
room for for research social behavior so
screw a calendars no calendar
festivities could also drive influence
them and you have some problems with the
support to this theory that is
contradictory data some places you'll
find something or like in friends they
found that the holidays reduce
transmission about the kids twenty
thirty percent but not in other places
and is inconsistent the seasonal
patterns we see with the school calendar
so influenza peaks during the winter in
temperate locations are not doing full
of spring holiday and you know under the
holidays don't coincide as they should
tropical epidemics do not necessarily
overlap with the school calendar what
about major events so in Brazil we saw
again we have so desired
data from the green correspond to the
green this is the data front mainly from
belen and in the Amazon so you see this
is the rainy season and then you have
more influence a circulating but
actually from the date of some years we
saw a pic here you know out of phase say
okay let's try to look at that and then
at that time of the year actually you
have one of the biggest religious event
in the world so you have people coming
from in all sorts of ways you know
through the city and then you say well
maybe this is driving seasonality in
some way there or that peak and then
it's let me skip this one but then what
we found is that the peaks this only
happen in one year so it was exactly
when the time of the event in one year
but not not enough to drive seasonality
other years so it's not rule out that
social events can a sporadic lee trigger
a cycle of transmission but there is
little support that social events drive
seasonal patterns ok and then so the
theory that change that changes in
contact ray ray to drive seasonal
pattern of influenza and other
respiratory disease remain one of the
most persistent myth in the field
because there is not hard data not
because it's it's necessarily wrong it
can be wrong but people just reproduce
this without having a still enough
empirical data another one then now we
move to the survival and transport of
pathogens outside hosts so when we is
needs we caught the virus did the trick
of activating us to spell it short side
ok it did the job of multi black
multiply insiders and now it needs to go
to another one and one way very clever
way of doing that is to stimulate us to
release in a very strong way you know
the things out there but then
to reach another host right a clever guy
this is he before anybody else you know
he was already speculating about that
people often catch code from one another
when shut up together in closed rooms
codes etc and when sitting near and
converse the conversing so as to breathe
in each other transportation so this is
just to pay an homage before they knew
about you know the gin theory and so on
Benjamin Franklin we're already thinking
of what we are talking here and then
they saw their main routes is this what
so these virus that is here if we wants
to get here we think that those are the
ways he can do it one is the airborne
transport you know so people is nice and
somebody else is going to inhale that
virus is right away and then this can be
with aerosols and droplets on depend on
the size as we are going to see they can
have a different route they can just
float until they reach here or they can
actually come in intermediate objects
contaminate then you put your hand on
that and because we are all the time
touching our faces and so on you will
self-inking inoculate the virus okay and
this is the size of this is a hair human
hair you know this is a sand beach sand
and these will be the size of the red
ones here of the aerosols that can float
from one bit to the other and much forty
percent is contained when we sneeze is
contained in this size okay the arrows
analyzed form when we so what is also
that when one day when the virus is out
there before it reached the other host
something that actually can stop it from
going there is several conditions
environmental conditions one there that
has been speculated in solar radiation
okay so since they have you know the
virus they have sensitivity to UV
radiation they get to destroy they get
in activated during low Sun seasons okay
the problems perhaps of deep theory is
that the amount of UV indoors with a
large proportion of influence a
transmission probably occurs is constant
okay so we still don't know about that
it's a possibility humidity so this is a
this is a big one actually and the as
you go sim so the lip envelope encasing
the virus remains intact longer when the
air is sufficiently cold and dry as the
aerosol eyes virus particle enters the
upper respiratory tract the envelop
melts exposing the virus to healthy host
cells so it's fascinating how many
studies actually saw that in low in low
humidity as you can see in those
simplification of graphics you have a
higher higher vital survival k low
humidity low humidity virus survival
bigger these in this study they had an
increased at after certain threshold and
then that they did so some experiments
are very interesting so they use
mannequins actually one is the one that
is the coughing simulator and the other
day breathing simulator and then they
measure you know the percentage of virus
that has retained that retains
infectivity relative to prior coughing
so very you know I'm trying to simulate
a realistic situation and they collected
the samples during 60 minutes and again
as you can see in the graphic in
conditions of low relativity the the
infectivity remains very high but if you
put in a wet environment it gets the
survival gets very low well and this
happens with the different size of the
of the particles
skip this one I'm another very
interesting experiment is actually with
ferret so what you do here is you put 21
faretta one in further that is infected
with influenza in one cage and then you
put another 10 guinea pigs but do they
do this with further to the one so yeah
briefly and then what you do you send an
airflow in the air flow in this
direction and then you see you know this
is the nasa wash tighter you know of
influenza virus in the infected of
course it gets decreasing as after the
animal gets sick but then the other one
this post has a peak okay so when you
have a low relative humidity the
transmission is one hundred percent this
is amazing but when it's in high
relative humidity that transmission is
zero so this is a very strong argument
in this in this sense you know very
powerful and then it is when you have
that so the temperature here it was 20
degrees when the temperature is low
actually what you have is that it
happened the same okay so transmission
one hundred percent at low relative
humidity fifty percent here at you see
when the temperature is low it gets
still just to get transmission but lower
in low in high humidity in date in in
warm water they only did one set of
experiments so unless you can see that
in 30 degrees the guinea pigs they have
zero transmission when you have a low
relative humidity so the virus somehow
doesn't like also they warm weather so
and the temperature with temperature we
were talking about humidity but with
temperature we have the same sort of
viral survival and viruses stability you
know
sort of shape you know so it increases
it decreases as the temperature
increases and when you put everything
together and you get absolute humidity
you still have this relation so because
airborne transmission seems to be more
sensitive to changes in temperature and
humidity it has been hypothesized that
the dominant mode mode of will be
airborne route in temperate regions and
droplet mode in tropics so that that
looks conclusive enough right but why
despite all support we can still
conclude that we cannot conclude that
virus survival is the mekinese driving
the seasonality of respiratory
infections well first the viruses might
be so fragile because they do not okay
is that well written but their message
is that the virus may they are they
perhaps are so fragile you know that
they actually cannot stand anyway
sometime I mean outside so virus that
persists in the extracellular
environment for considerable periods
must be more stable than those that pass
quickly from one host to the next so
what I mean is that perhaps the
influenza virus the respiratory virus
that you actually don't need to resist
to stand environmental conditions
because they go quickly from one host to
the other so these viruses are often
unstable outside about the body spreding
request closed person-to-person contact
is this what this author said another
problem is that this hypothesis does not
explain a data from tropical areas okay
when you have a high humidity in
coincides with a with the epidemic
season and the third alternatives have a
perhaps more solid perhaps the
alternative theories have we don't know
they have more solid biological basis
that is my my belief actually I think
the
because our respiratory tract is exposed
much longer to external conditions that
the respiratory virus are it seems
reasonable suspect that respiratory
infections might be mediated by changes
in the respiratory tract so let's
explore this dispersibility this
gentleman he was the one that discovered
that actually shingle shingles were
caused by chickenpox Utley and he was at
the core of the debate of the role of
population humidity and overall
susceptibility to infection and he
proposed that the simultaneous what
happens that you have the virus
circulating in non instinct or less
hosts but then when you have the right
conditions your immune system somehow
lower its kappa capacity capability of
fighting against then and then is when
you get symptomatic influenza or
symptomatic illness and he and he
defended that decision Oh a stimulus for
that was deficiency in vitamin D it
makes sense because determined e is it
acts as an immune system modulator right
and some clinical trials tests actually
if vitamin D supplements affect the
incidence of influence in school-age
children and they had mixed the result
result so here it is actually another
idea for an experiment you know can
vitamin D you can get in you know from
CBS CBS and then you can give to some
people and to others give plus able and
see if they have less influenza or
respiratory disease this is something
that would be very interesting to
perform this experiment so we have
challenged to allocate resources pensive
a physiological process thermal
regulation so for instance when you are
actually fighting I mean if you are in
winter
you have to take care of temperature of
nutrition you know you sometimes get wet
and this and that so this is a location
of resource of energy that probably you
are removing from being able to fight a
disease so this is another possibility
and then nutrition as well okay an in
nutrition let's just meet up in our
parentheses an interesting this study we
are doing actually we got these records
from Chinese 15th century medical
officer from the Ming Dynasty and you
know that other problem they didn't have
a lot of that time they didn't have a
lot of drama of using people you know to
do experiments and then they used to so
from some part of them they force
ingestion of lime water you know then
diet consists only of rice and
vegetables disposer to upload
temperatures change and then it will the
lucky ones they gave a soup you know and
so on and actually this is a in from the
design point of view it's a made a
practice is actually the first clinical
trial documenting the history is very
fascinating and they use 50 individuals
in each of these groups okay the problem
is that they didn't inter SPECT very
well they're their groups they had to be
good you know because they could be
beheaded and sewn by the by the
Emperor's this is the the if they didn't
get you know they good you know
treatment to the Emperor family so they
really did very good experiment from the
point of view of design but this was not
the world is inter SPECT but still it's
fascinating but because that experiment
at that time can give us results that
all the prisoners that had this
treatment you know that they were
nutritionally suppressed they actually
developed ila symptoms ok code and only
a few prisoners developed in this in
this group so very interesting historic
data
seasonal exposure to cold air causes an
increase in the incidence of upper
respiratory tract infections do it to
cooling of the nasal airway okay this is
my favorite hypothesis okay I'm gonna
tell about my favorite one here this guy
a cliff from Wales he published this
paper and I think that for me is the one
that is my favorite the one that I would
like to see experiments trying to refute
80 or club or so an image for you here
ok so the season exposure to cold air
causes increase in the incidence ok
because it affects the nasal airway I he
had a figure there that we every day we
breathe fourteen thousand liters of air
how much is that so this is google it
you know and it came this image this is
a fourteen thousand liters you know tank
so this is what we each one of one of us
both inside our lank and send back to
the atmosphere per day this is a huge
amount of things you know that can be so
this is the amount of what I mean is
this is the amount of atmosphere that we
put inside this very fragile part of us
that is the respiratory epithelium okay
because we need to do the exchange of
gases in the in the lungs because we
need to keep it wet and so on it's not
like a skin you know that is very well
protected so you are bringing this huge
amount of Earth of air in contact to
something that is basically not perhaps
not that prepared for doing that or it
is because we are live but I mean so the
theory of the guy is this one you have
breathing of cold air because of that
the temperature of the nasal epithelium
decreases right and then the mucosal
ciliary clearance activity of yours cell
there and the phagocytic
tivity they also decrease because of
that you have an increased
susceptibility to infection that led to
upper respiratory tract infections I
think that this makes a lot of sense
because when you expose these epithelium
you know of your of your respiratory
tract what you have is some very
interesting defenses you know you're so
you have the secreted mucus you know
that is a liquid viscosa stink that
actually is going to get the dust and
the virus and all of that and with the
movement of the Celia is going to bring
to some place that you can swallow that
and take to the your digestive system
assistant where is going to be destroyed
so this is the part where you can break
the defense you know you can with the go
there with offensive circumstances you
can break that and open the window for
the entrance of pathogens this for me
makes a lot of sense and then the
problems some experiments with the
guinea pigs that I think that I'm not
going to be able to go through them but
as but we can handle that that criticism
and then another one is well let me just
give you an idea of another experiment
here right so I think that would be very
interesting I was mentioned to to Ginny
today one experiment that will be very
cool to do is if you detect you know
putative changes in the respiratory
epithelium you know of a population
prior of the time of when people get
infected so they the changes in the
respiratory epithelium could not be
attributed to the virus than cells but
to the conditions that you are exposed
and then you will see see if after these
conditions you would have more
invasion of violence I think that this
will be very conclusive and you could do
just with the nasal swabs from the
hospital hands on the problems for
another problem is actually that does
not explain the circulation in the
tropics right because in the tropics you
would think well when it's raining while
you would have you know your epithelium
being affected by these conditions so
those are some of the ideas that I've
been actually been discussing with this
researcher changes in the viscosity of
the Italian mucosa you know you can have
perhaps in the same way when you breathe
this you know when you put it is my
machines to clean your throat and all of
that maybe the damp conditions of the
tropic also change the viscosity of the
epithelium and that could open perhaps
the win the windows to our infections
frequency of both respiration allowing
pathogens to bypass defense systems so
when is hot and wet people breathe more
with the mouth so that maybe bypass your
defenses you know of the nose no it's a
speculation and well I I I read this in
the literature more allergens and
conditions could facilitate the damage
to epithelial hence a viral invasion so
those who does will be the depart
regarding to the causal factors let me
just change a little bit here and I
think that perhaps this will be the last
one because I mean not how are we on
time yeah examples of practical
implications of the current theories to
public health so this is fascinating not
only because the scientific things but
because when you are giving
recommendations of what we you should do
the mechanisms and the environmental
route they change they if it's one or
the other actually changed completely
radically
recommendations that you would give so
for instance if it's a nasal airway one
solution will be what you should
recommend people is to use I scarf you
know because then you are avoid to a lot
of cold air getting into you and doing
that damage you know so old people they
they die more in winter so the use of a
scar because first predatory disease so
the use of looks like a sensible thing
to recommend to them to do if it's very
survival actually are not these actually
what causes more deaths in winter the
very survival so the recommendation is
completely different you will say okay
so what you have to do is to humidify or
indoor air for instance this will be one
of them or you would for instance also
so I here and then the environmental
roots if it's also you would say is the
isolation or use of phase my mask okay
if they the virus go go's floating into
their this is what you have to do but if
is self inoculation by hand as we saw
the other route the other possibility
that we don't know then is washing hands
okay so you can see that actually the
whole basis of the recommendation for
the two thousand pandemic actually was
based on the assumptions that we were
that the virus would transmit into by by
hand by itself inoculation okay because
the main recommendation was washing
hands and actually we publish an article
that showing that even if so that
wouldn't be a big difference because
people have a lot of opportunities to
reckon damn innate their hands in
between wash handing event okay i think
that is time for me I have a I'm
mysterion I have a lot plenty of things
to talk the whole afternoon here but I
will not bore you I think that I can
finish because it's time to that and if
you have questions we have some time to
thank you